[Musique]
Bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans
scienceclic trou noir et cône de lumière
imaginons qu'on allumer une bougie
la bougie et met un flash de lumière qui
se propage dans toutes les directions
formant une bulle qui grossit
cette bulle et à trois dimensions et
nous englobe complètement
si l'on se trouve à l'intérieur il est
impossible d'en sortir car il faudrait
de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière
imaginons qu'on observe qu'une tranche
de l'espace à deux dimensions
la bulle forme un cercle qui grossit
tout autour de nous
[Musique]
si on décompose la situation image par
image et que l'on aligne les images les
unes derrière les autres on peut
construire un diagramme dans lequel
cette bulle de lumière qui grossit tu au
cours du temps forme un cône
ce cône s'élargit du passé vers le futur
et à l'intérieur notre à son une
trajectoire à travers le temps
les parois du cône sont incliné à 45°
car la lumière parcourt toujours en en
même temps une même distance par exemple
en un an la lumière parcourt toujours
une distance de une année-lumière dans
l'espace
ce type d'objets et ce qu'on appelle un
cône de lumière à mesure que le temps
s'écoule le connais s'élargit à la
vitesse de la lumière et quoi que l'on
fasse notre trajectoire reste confiné à
l'intérieur il nous est impossible d'en
ressortir
relativité c'est cône de lumière sont
essentiels pour comprendre la structure
de l'univers il permet notamment de
restreindre les relations de cause à
effet
pour comprendre imaginons un événement
qui se produit à une certaine distance
de la Terre par exemple une explosion de
supernova
cet événement ne pourra affecter la
terre que lorsque son cône de lumière
nous aura atteint
avance la aucune information sur
l'explosion ne peut nous parvenir car
rien ne peut se transmettre plus vite
que la lumière
cette explosion ne pourra être vu et
ressenti sur terre qu'à partir du moment
où l'on n'entre dans son cône de lumière
la causalité le fait qu'un événement
puisse en déclencher un autre est limité
par la vitesse de la lumière
mets-les cône de lumière permettent
surtout de comprendre la différence
fondamentale entre les notions de temps
et l'espace
quelle est la différence entre le temps
[Musique]
dans l'espace on peut se déplacer dans
n'importe quelle direction faire
demi-tour ou encore suivre une
trajectoire qui reboucle sur elle-même
en ce qui concerne le temps tous les
objets sont destinés à se déplacer dans
un même sens
dans le temps il est impossible de faire
demi-tour aussi des places forcément du
passé vers le futur
[Musique]
les cônes de lumière permet de bien voir
cette différence dans l'espace on est
libre de choisir n'importe quelle
direction
mais dans le temps les cône de lumière
successifs nous oblige pas à avancer
toujours vers le Futur on ne peut pas
faire demi-tour car il est impossible de
sortir déconne de lumière
cette propriété va nous permettre de
définir plutôt rigoureusement ce qu'on
appelle le temps
le temps en relativité et simplement la
direction dans laquelle sont orientés
les cônes de lumière
c'est cette direction suivant laquelle
on peut pas faire demi-tour
cette direction vers laquelle. Toutes
les trajectoires possibles et dans
laquelle se situe forcément notre futur
l'espace quant à lui est l'ensemble des
autres directions perpendiculaires
autant
[Musique]
dans une zone où l'univers est vide en
l'absence de gravité sa structure
l'espace-temps est régulière le temps et
l'espace font une grille ordonné
rectiligne et les cônes de lumières sont
tous alignés dans une même direction
on peut ainsi définir le temps de façon
globale dans ce diagramme le temps va
globalement de la gauche vers la droite
mais imaginons maintenant que l'univers
contient un astre très massif comme par
exemple la terre
sur la une pomme en altitude la pomme va
peu à peu être entraîné vers le bas
dévié par la gravité de la planète
mais si la gravité entraîne la matière
elle entraîne également la lumière et si
la pomme émet des bulles de lumière au
cours du temps la lumière va elle aussi
être entraîné vers le bas
[Musique]
à proximité d'un astre massif les cônes
de lumières ne sont plus aligner les uns
après les autres ils tournent peu à peu
courbé par la gravité
à proximité d'un astre Macif la
direction déconne de lumière se penche
en d'autres termes le temps est courbé
vers le centre de la planète
si la pomme tombe alors qu'il était
initialement immobile c'est parce que
son futur est dirigée vers le bas
les astres d'histoire de la géométrie de
l'univers l'espace et le temps sont des
notions relatives dont l'orientation
dépend de l'endroit où on se place c'est
la relativité générale
plus et massifs plus il court de
l'espace-temps
mais imaginons un objet massif et très
compact
un astre de ce type engendre est une
courbure telle qu'en dessous d'une
certaine altitude les cône de lumière
serait complètement d'orienter vers le
bas
si on allume une bougie à cet endroit
tous les rayons lumineux quel que soit
leur direction de départ serait destiné
à tomber vers le centre
c'est ce qu'on appelle un trou noir
un trou noir est une région ferrique de
l'univers une sorte de bulle dans
laquelle la courbure de l'espace-temps
entraîne tous les objets vers le centre
[Musique]
si on observe qu'une tranche de l'espace
à deux dimensions le trou noir forment
un cercle qui reste statique et trace un
cylindre dans l'espace-temps
la frontière du trou noir et ce qu'on
appelle l'horizon
au-dessus de l'horizon certains rayons
lumineux peuvent s'échapper à la gravité
mets sous l'horizon toute la lumière et
capturer
dans un trou noir les cône de lumière
confine la trajectoire de n'importe quel
objet vers le bas le temps lui-même est
dirigé vers le centre du trou noir
pour comprendre ce qui est réellement un
trou noir il va être intéressant
d'envisager deux points de vue différent
celui d'un astronaute qui tombe dans le
trou noir et celui d'un observateur
lointain stationner à grande distance
pour l'observateur lointain la gravité
est très faible dans son voisinage la
grille d'espace et de temps et régulière
pour lui le temps c'est cool de la
gauche vers la droite
l'horizon du trou noir semble immobile
il trace une ligne droite du passé vers
le futur
mais observons maintenant le point de
vue de l'astronaute qui tombe
à mesure qu'il se rapproche de l'horizon
le temps et l'espace pivote peu à peu
courbé par la présence du trou noir
et lorsqu'il atteint enfin l'horizon du
trou noir l'astronaute ne s'en rend pas
compte mais à cet endroit le temps et
l'espace sont penchées à 45° par rapport
à l'observateur lointain
pour cet astronaute l'horizon n'est pas
une ligne horizontale du passé vers le
futur mais une diagonale qui monte à 45
degrés
exactement comme la surface d'un cône de
lumière
[Musique]
alors que l'observateur lointain voit le
trou noir immobile pour l'instant note
au niveau de l'horizon le temps et
l'espace sont inclinés si bien que le
trou noir se comporte comme un cône de
lumière
ce qui explique qu'il est impossible
d'en sortir
lorsqu'il franchit l'horizon les notions
de temps et d'espace semble tu
interchanger par rapport à l'extérieur
le temps est désormais vers le bas ce
qui était avant une direction dans
l'espace
l'horizon du trou noir n'est plus un
endroit dans l'espace mes annonces temps
dans notre passé
et le centre du trou noir n'est plus un
point mais un événement dans notre futur
un destin auquel on échappera pas
sous l'horizon tous les objets sont
inéluctablement car c'est dans cette
direction que se trouvent leur futur
lorsqu'une étoile massive s'effondre sur
elle-même elle et met interne et flash
de lumière une dernière bulle qui tente
de grossir mais dans un espace temps
penchée à 45° Courbet par la masse de
l'étoile si bien que la bulle semble
figer depuis l'extérieur
un trou noir s'est formé
c'est un cône de lumière rendu immobile
par la courbure de l'espace-temps
redressant le diagramme on rétablit une
direction du temps global de la gauche
vers la droite
dans ce diagramme redresser on voit tu
explicitement que l'horizon du trou noir
forme un cône de lumière émergent depuis
l'étoile qui s'effondre et depuis
l'intérieur duquel il est impossible de
ressortir une fois sous l'horizon ce
cône force notre trajectoire a heurté le
centre du trou noir là où la courbure
devient si intense que nos modèle ne
fonctionne plus
le centre du trou noir et un événement
dans le futur
enfin si l'on compact hi-fi ce diagramme
on obtient d'un diagramme de Penrose
dans lequel l'extérieur et l'intérieur
du trou noir forme de régions distinctes
et dès lors qu'on franchit l'horizon le
reste de l'univers se situe derrière
nous dans notre passé il nous est
impossible durée accéder
notre seul futur possible et de ton vers
inéluctablement vers la singularité
[Musique]